hey everyone out there
thank you so much for tuning in to
another edition of market takes here
with me dion robon reporter at the wall
street journal we are going through all
things markets everything that's
important to the market and i'm going to
be breaking down what you need to be
watching out for if you're an investor
if you got a 401k if you're watching the
economy which really i think all of us
should be right now i'm going to talk
about what's going on this week what to
look out for and how to read that
interpret it and really kind of navigate
through
all the important market moving things
that we're going to get this week
this week to me when i look out at what
we've got coming the slate of data
releases it's all about the federal
reserve all about the fed and we are
going to learn a lot about what the fed
thinks what they're doing and what
they've done and we're also going to get
some information about some new data
that they'll be looking at and really
having to dig and dive deep into as they
make their decision on monetary policy
in june that's coming up so
this week it's all about the fed we get
the minutes from their last fomc meeting
which was in uh in may that's this
month's meeting we get those minutes on
wednesday afternoon and then on friday
we will get the pce personal consumption
expenditures report that's the fed's
favorite measure of inflation so we get
that friday morning i think those are
going to be very big and very important
to the market
as we move forward now
what we've got right now in the market
uh if you don't know now you know it's
been a rough couple months really in the
market and particularly rough as we look
out we finally are starting to see some
green today you've got the dow up almost
two percent as i look on the wsj.com the
s p 500 up more than one and a half
percent and the nasdaq up a little bit
more than one percent as well i'm
looking at uh bonds you've got the
10-year treasury yield down some or up
some excuse me today those bond prices
down a little bit we're seeing oil
prices around neutral uh really kind of
stuck at that 110 dollars a barrel level
uh where it has been for the past couple
weeks
also seeing some moves uh in gold we're
seeing gold up a little less than half
percent today but seeing those those
moves where the market is you know the
stock market is finally starting to
bounce back we're starting to see some
green but the big question i think any
investor has to be thinking right now is
will this continue is this real is this
what they call a dead cat bounce where
you know the market has gone down so
much that now it's picking back up just
a little bit or is this you know the
start of something consistent we shall
see um right now the dow has been in a
losing streak for eight straight weeks
it's been down every week for eight
straight weeks that is the longest
weekly losing streak since april of 1932
so that tells you the kind of territory
that we're in it's also been down 13 of
the past 15 weeks the s p 500 and the
nasdaq both on seven week losing streaks
that is the longest since march of 2001
for both of those so 1932 2001 not good
years not what you want to be comparing
yourself to uh when it comes to the
stock market if you are a long investor
on the bond side we're seeing kind of
the opposite we've seen bond prices
really start to pick up three of the of
the last three days of last week we saw
the u.s treasury market bond prices
rising which means those yields were
declining
and we saw that and it looks like we
could be moving into a different pattern
we've seen for about the past two months
or so stock prices going down and bond
prices going down we're seeing a little
bit of divergence for that
today you see stock prices going up bond
prices going down but we've seen kind of
the opposite the last couple weeks both
the 10-year and the two-year yield both
declined three of the past four weeks so
that's good if you're a bond investor
but if you're just looking at what that
means the economy generally means
there's some fear in the market it means
investors are a little bit worried about
the the pace and the growth of the
economy uh oil prices up three of the
last four weeks
that's definitely something to watch out
for i was talking to peter atwater he is
a professor of economics at william and
mary who specializes in sentiment and
sentiment indicators he says that no
one's really watching these oil prices
and i'll quote you what he said he says
if this continues they're going to be
big problems for the consumer that
nobody is even thinking about today so
keep your eye on oil prices i think
that's something that we haven't been
talking enough about as we sit at this
level over 110 dollars per barrel so
again what to watch for this week we get
those minutes from the fomc meeting
that's the federal reserves rate setting
committee when they had their meeting at
the beginning of this month we get the
minutes from that which are going to
tell us what they talked about and talk
about the meeting we also get that pce
report on friday morning and the sneaky
important uh piece of data that i think
everyone needs to watch out for this
week it's the first revision of the us
first quarter gdp report that sounds
like a snooze fest but i'm going to tell
you why you need to watch out for that
this week so let's jump right into it
the fomc meeting minutes are released
wednesday afternoon i think all eyes
from the market are going to be on this
normally not a lot of attention gets
paid if you're you know a highly
sophisticated bond investor this is
something you watch if you're you know a
private or a an asset manager at one of
these larger firms or something you
watch but the average everyday person
probably doesn't watch the fomc minutes
i think that's changing uh this week and
i think this week will probably be the
most watched fomc minutes in quite some
time
now what those minutes are if you are
not a regular observer of this or
someone who doesn't regularly check in
with those fomc minutes it really just
gives you a bit more granular detail
about what was said and what happened at
the meeting fed chair jerome powell
after the meeting he comes out he he
gives a speech he talks to the media for
half an hour and you get to find out
what the chairman's thinking what he's
hearing what he believes to be happening
with the economy but you don't hear from
anyone else on the fed well we get the
minutes from that meeting and we get to
find out okay here's what was really
said here's what they really talked
about here's what they really thought so
you get some views from specific members
of the fed they'll say oh a number of
members said this a few members said
that a majority of members felt this way
and savvy investors can really dig
through these minutes and find oh well
this could be a trend this could be the
end of a trend the fed could be moving
in this direction rather than that
direction
and i think right now where the fed is
really driving the economy with these
rate increases and potentially you know
putting us on the doorstep of a possible
recession
that's something that i think is really
going to be very informative for
investors and for folks who are watching
the economy now like i said even if
you're not managing 10 billion dollars
you probably want to know what's going
to be going on with the economy and one
of the reasons i think this this
particular uh slate of fomc minutes is
going to be so important and impactful
is because there have just been growing
recession fears now uh for some time
we're starting to see communication from
the federal reserve from chair jerome
powell that this soft landing that has
been you know kind of
hinted at and suggested that the federal
reserve could do
might not really come to pass
if you remember a few months ago fed
chair jerome powell said we believe that
we can engineer a soft landing uh and
then he kind of moved too well a soft
dish landing and then recently in in
comments with uh the wall street journal
and others in the media he said we can't
guarantee that there will be a soft
landing essentially a soft landing means
the economy has been kind of soaring
through the air like a plane and now the
fed's got to bring it down by raising
those interest rates and slowing down
the economy
making it more expensive to borrow money
making businesses kind of pull back on
some of the expansion they're doing
and those sorts of things which are
designed to you know they really are
designed to slow the economy which means
hiring is going to slow uh the fed chair
jerome palace said himself he expects
the unemployment rate to start to pick
up a little bit a soft landing would
mean you know we can do all those things
without having unemployment really pick
up significantly without having a
painful recession and you're starting to
see the fed back off of that soft
landing uh we saw at the end of april
deutsche bank's economists say we are
expecting a not just a recession which
they said earlier they said now we're
expecting the coming recession will be
worse than expected we saw goldman sachs
senior chairman lloyd blankfein
come out last week and say there is a
very very high risk of a us recession
we saw former federal reserve chairman
ben bernanke say that the fed's slow
response to inflation was a quote
mistake and that he sees stagflation as
likely now both of those things i want
to hit those separately uh stagflation
really is a major worry of economists
because it means the unemployment rate
is going up at the same time as prices
keep going up so for regular folks out
there they have less job security they
could be losing their jobs that raise
that they were hoping to get maybe
doesn't happen because business is
slowing down at the same time as you've
got less job security maybe less money
in your bank account or in your wallet
prices are still rising at a fast pace
that's stagflation and that's a major
worry for economists
like former fed chair ben bernanke and
the fed's response to inflation if we
remember last year the fed said
inflation is transitory transitory
transitory and as we move through the
year and inflation just kept picking up
and rising faster and faster we saw that
that was incorrect towards the end of
the year they said hey you know what we
don't think this thing is transitory
we're going to retire that term and
we're gonna start taking action they've
started doing that now we have seen two
straight meetings with rate increases
and we expect to see the fed raising
rates at more than double time or at
least double time at this meeting in
june and at the meeting in july maybe
even pushing out into uh september so
again
we are talking about what's going on
this is all about the federal reserve
this is my live stream thank you so much
by the way this is the number one live
stream on my personal youtube channel
for the wall street journal so i
appreciate you tuning in for that and
for being with us we're talking about
the fomc minutes why those are important
we get those wednesday afternoon and
we're going to be talking about the pce
inflation report that comes out friday
morning so thanks for being with us i am
appreciate you guys tuning in now the
other reason those fomc minutes are
going to be really important is the cpi
which is the other more followed
inflation report really didn't give us a
definitive answer on the economy it was
high but not too high it was higher than
expectations but still below the number
that we got the previous month so
inflation still running above eight
percent according to the cpi but slowing
down so maybe we peaked but maybe we
haven't there was really a lot of
uncertainty from that report
and it suggested inflation could be
stickier than we had previously thought
so definitely something to watch out for
when we get this pc report on friday but
also the fomc minutes how's the fed
thinking about inflation as they went
into that meeting did they think okay
well if pce and cpi come in below then
we can kind of take our foot off the gas
or did they think oh you know what even
if they're at that eight percent level
and moving in the direction we want
we've still got a lot more work to do
and we hope as you know as folks who are
watching the economy that we'll get some
more detail on that
other big piece of information that we
got last week i talked to you all about
housing housing housing uh housing
prices continued to rise at a very fast
pace
existing home sales rose at about 15
percent year over year also home builder
sentiment was the lowest in two years
again when we watch those home builders
sentiment numbers it's because we don't
have enough supply there aren't enough
houses out there for folks who are
buying and that's what's keeping those
prices rising well if homebuilder
sentiment is low it means they don't see
a path to extreme profitability or to
increase profitability by building more
homes that sentiment is low for building
homes means less supply likely come into
the market that could mean that prices
continue to pick up and rise even higher
don't forget i talked to you about this
on on previous live streams and previous
videos i've done expectations for
economists were for only about five
percent growth in housing prices this
year we're at 15 consistently so far
this year
last thing i want to get to is the other
thing that we could see in that fomc
minute in those fomc minutes is some
details about the balance sheet runoff
aka qt aka quantitative tightening
meaning the federal reserve for the past
two years has been pushing massive and
massive amounts of money out into the
economy a lot of that gone into the
stock market now they're not only
stopping that but they're going to be
sucking that money out of the economy
doing less and doing instead of bond
buying they're going to be tightening
the economy so definitely something to
watch out for
last but not least thing i want to make
sure and hit is this pce inflation
report we get friday morning will that
decline like cpi um will we see it move
down lower than where it was in march or
will it peak higher cpi and pce normally
move in the same direction but they are
different reports so we could see
different outcomes
again
ppi or cpce excuse me pce measures
things differently than cpi one of the
big differences is that pce is more
weighted towards business surveys and
cpi is more weighted towards household
surveys essentially they call households
and regular homes and say hey what are
you spending what are you buying what
were the prices that you paid whereas
pce is much more focused on businesses
what did you sell um it also reflects
different ways of tracking so pce tracks
uh you know all the prices that are paid
so for example if with the p with the
cpi right when you're looking at that
report if you go to your doctor and you
have an out-of-pocket cost of 20 last
month and this month it's 25
that'll be reflected in cpi but if your
insurance was paying 50 now they're
paying sixty dollars that won't be
cracked into cpi that is tracked into pc
so all that to say that pce could move
higher and if that happens and rather
than
um see pce having peaked in march being
the highest that it's been in 40 years
that number could go higher if that
number goes higher in april than it was
for march
the fed could be back to square one and
have to say oh my goodness
move even faster than we expected this
prediction that we had that inflation
had peaked in march and had gotten as
high as it was going to get was
incorrect well now we've got to maybe
move even faster and do even more uh to
get inflation under control that would
be a really bad sign for the market and
that's why this is a report that i think
everyone should be watching i think it's
going to be box office on friday morning
make sure you tune in to the pce release
um
the sneaky important report for this
week that's that q1 gdp report the
second or the first revision it's the
second version of it this is important
because we are halfway to a recession
now a lot of economists have brushed
this off they say ah there's more noise
than signal
and that the u.s economy still isn't a
good place because that negative figure
that we got for q1 the first time was
mostly the result of uh less growth in
inventories and a big trade imbalance
meaning
the u.s bought more from overseas from
other buyers people like china the
european union south america etc then
they sold to those nations and that
number meant that we actually had a
contraction growth declined instead of
growing
in the first quarter
does that get confirmed
and what's what happens with that
basically the gd gdp report is just the
government goes out and says hey how was
business how much did you sell and they
send a report out to let's call it 100
different businesses usually in the
first report they only get reports back
from 50 businesses by the second one
they've heard back from 70 by the third
one they've heard back from 90. so you
get a better report and more uh you know
a bit more
of a detailed look at more businesses
when you get that revision so
that's coming out on thursday morning
check that because i think it will
either confirm or deny this negative
path that we're on in terms of gdp
um and that's that's really about it
this week like i said i think those fomc
minutes are going to be the big market
driver this week then you've got the pc
report on friday and in between that on
thursday you'll want to look out for
that first quarter gdp first revision
it's a lot it's a little nerdy but if
you care about the economy and you want
to be ahead of the game definitely
something to watch listen that's going
to do it for this live stream thank you
for tuning in with us i am dion robowen
reporter for the wall street journal
this is market takes we are going to do
it again next monday at one o'clock p.m
eastern time i hope you'll be there
don't be a
and tune in and join in with me all
right that's gonna do it for us here on
market takes thanks for being with us
let's do it again on monday